[Applaus]
[Musik]
bevor wir beginnen würde ich euch gerne
eine kleine Frage stellen habt ihr euch
nicht auch schon mal gefragt inwiefern
Russland wirklich ein kapitalistisches
Land ist nur eine stimmt zwar das in
Russland vor rund 30 Jahren der
sowjetische Kommunismus
zusammengebrochen ist aber inwiefern
konnte sich infolgedessen eine Art
freier und kapitalistischer Markt wie in
den USA oder in Europa ausbilden ich
meine damit jeden einigermaßen guten
Kapitalismus der ein gesundes
Gleichgewicht der Machtkräfte zulässt
denn was wir aktuell in Russland haben
ist natürlich auch Kapitalismus aber
einer der übelsten Sorte
[Applaus]
was ich in diesem Land entwickelt hat
ist ein massiv unausgewogener Raubtier
und klicken Merkantilismus der weltweit
seinesgleichen sucht rund 500
Superreiche Russen kontrollieren mehr
Vermögen als die ersten 99,8 Prozent an
eine derart krasse Ungleichverteilung
und wahrlich kein anderes Land heran
diese reisten 500 die weniger als
0,001 Prozent der russischen Bevölkerung
ausmachen besitzen mit insgesamt 640
Milliarden Dollar mehr als die Ärmsten
115 Millionen der erwachsenen
Bevölkerung diejenigen von euch die
visualpolitik schon etwas länger
verfolgen wissen dass wir uns schon in
so manchen Video damit befasst haben was
innerhalb Russland so vor sich geht ein
tiefes Verständnis Russlands ist
notwendig nicht nur um zu verstehen wie
es zu Putins Angriff auf die Ukraine
kommen konnte sondern auch um eine
qualifizierte Prognose über die Zukunft
Russlands und Europas abgeben zu können
denn eines ist klar Russland mag sich
zwar noch immer für eine Militärmacht
halten aber was das Wohlergehen seine
Bürger angeht ist dieses Land weit von
dem entfernt was wir als entwickelte
Welt bezeichnen
[Musik]
okay manche werden sicherlich einwenden
aber Marc ich war schon mal in Moskau
und es sah dort genauso aus wie in jeder
anderen europäischen Großstadt nun das
kann gut sein aber man darf nicht
vergessen dass Russland riesig ist und
abseits der großen Städte gibt es
Regionen wie die Republik Karelien mit
einem pro Kopf BIP das dem Libyens
entspricht oder zum Beispiel Nord Ostsee
ziehen das wirtschaftlich mit einem
afrikanischen landwirtjibuti
vergleichbar ist Russland ist zwar reich
eine Rohstoffen wie z.B Erdgas Erdöl
Palladium und Nickel aber seine Bürger
sehen von diesen Reichtum nur sehr wenig
manche fragen sich sogar ob die Zeit der
kommunistischen Herrschaft für sie nicht
sogar besser war aber hört euch mal an
was Putin selbst auf diese rasantimos
entgegnet wer die Sowjetunion nicht
vermisst hat kein Herz wer sie sich
zurückwünscht keinen Verstand gut über
die Themen Freiheit und Demokratie
spricht man im heutigen Russland lieber
nicht und jeder der ist dennoch fragt
sich Putin zu widersetzen läuft Gefahr
im Gefängnis zu landen oder sogar
vergiftet zu werden aber falls ihr treue
visualpolitik Zuschauer seid erzähle ich
euch ja nichts Neues wir haben schon
viele Videos darüber Putins
repressionssysteme und auch darüber wie
ungleich das Vermögen in Russland
verteilt ist und wenn ihr wissen wollt
wer aktuell die Macht über die
Wirtschaft Russlands hat solltet ihr
euch unser Video ansehen dass ich euch
hinter dem e-symbol und in der
Beschreibung verlinkt habe wie gesagt
und 500 Superreiche Russen kontrollieren
mehr Vermögen als die Ärmsten 99,8% des
Volkes im heutigen Video werden wir
daher genau ergründen wie es in Russland
überhaupt so weit kommen konnte denn was
alle wissen ist dass diese Geschichte
zwei Hauptakteure hat waren sie
hellsehen und Wladimir Putin die
wenigsten kennen jedoch die wahren
Gründe dafür warum der Übergang Russland
zum Liberalen Kapitalismus auf so krasse
Weise gescheitert ist denn warum ist
Russland so kläglich an dem gescheitert
was China und auch viele europäische
Post kommunistische Länder hinbekommen
haben und was ist passiert das Vladimir
Putin trotz seines kolossalen Versagens
heute noch immer alle Zügel Russlands so
fest in seiner Hand hält heute werden
wir all diese Fragen beantworten und
zwar wie so oft indem wir zuerst einen
kurzen Blick in die Geschichte werfen
gerne würde ich euch aber darauf
hinweisen dass Sie unsere Arbeit mit
einer Spende über den paypal-link in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video nutzen
könnt vielen Dank schon mal und jetzt ab
nach Moskau
das neue Russland
im September 1991 fand in Moskau eines
der größten Konzerte aller Zeiten statt
Monsters of Rock ein Konzert auf dem
größten Wiese black crows Pantera
Metallica und ac/dc eine gigantische
Menschenmasse von sage und schreibe 1,6
Millionen Russen in Ekstase versetzt
haben ihre Musik war jahrzehntelang vom
kommunistischen Regime zensiert worden
jetzt spielten sie dort mitten auf dem
Flugplatz von toscino in Moskau von den
Augen einer Zukunft hungrigen russischen
Jugend
[Musik]
[Applaus]
damit war klar dass ich die Dinge in
Russland radikal änderten und die
Schlüsselfigur dieser Veränderung war
Bares jetzt ihn zuerst gelang es ihm am
12 juli 1991 die erste demokratische
Wahl zum Präsidenten der russischen
sozialistischen Sowjetrepublik zu
gewinnen weißt du denn august 1991
Hardliner das zerfallenen sowjetischen
Institutionen die ihre Formen
Gorbatschow wie zum Beispiel Perestroika
und las nost mit Hilfe eines aufzuhalten
versuchten hatten sie jedoch ihre
Rechnung ohne barisiere gemacht er
schaffte es mit seiner Rede an die
Bürger in der er den Umsturz versucht
verurteilte die Rückkehr Gottes forderte
und an die Soldaten appellierte sich
nicht von Verbrechern
instrumentalisieren zu lassen ein
demokratischen Widerstand gegen die
Putschisten zu organisieren dieser würde
dann dazu dass sich drei Tage später der
Großteil der Soldaten zu Demokratie
bekannte und sich zu den Demonstranten
gesellte sowohl der Putsch als auch die
Sowjetunion als Ganzes waren damit
Geschichte der demokratische Prozess im
Landwirt immer umfassender und
unumkehrbarer die Menschen im Land
werden zu Herren ihres eigenen
Schicksals er wollte seine ganze
Popularität sein ganzes polit
bundeskapital dazu einsetzen den Wechsel
von einer staatlich kontrollierten
Wirtschaft zu einer liberalen
Marktwirtschaft zu beschleunigen was war
also das Problem und das Problem war das
der Übergang zum Kapitalismus viele
Schwierigkeiten mit sich brachte da
genießen
soweit streut durch Ischias kapitali so
Neues zum Beispiel herrschten die
Sowjets mit Hilfe umfassender
Preiskontrollen für fast alle waren gab
es einen staatlich festgelegten Preis
denn in vielen Fällen niedriger war als
der Weltmarktpreis
[Musik]
Anfang 1992 öffnet sich dann aber
Russland schlagartig für den Welthandel
mit freien Preisen für fast alle waren
und was ist daraufhin passiert richtig
die Preise für waren stiegen von einem
Tag auf den anderen in Schwindel
erregende Höhen während jedoch die
meisten Löhne und Renten immer noch auf
dem Niveau der sowjetszeit lieben mit
welchen Folgen explodierende Armut noch
größere Alkoholismus und es konnte sogar
eine Zunahme von Infektionskrankheiten
gemessen werden die durchschnittliche
Lebenserwartung daraus entbrach allein
innerhalb der vier Jahre von 1991 bis 94
und 5 Jahre ein von 69 auf 64 Jahre bei
Männern gar auf nur 58 das riesen Land
mit seinen endlosen Ackerflächen musste
aus dem Ausland ernährt werden und allen
Russen die diese Zeit erlebt haben sind
sicherlich noch all die Fleischdosen im
Gedächtnis geblieben die von NGOs aus
Finnland und anderen Nachbarländern
geschickt wurden aber wartet mal einen
Moment denn das war nicht das einzige
Problem fast alle ehemaligen
ostblock-länder litten in den 1990er
Jahren unter hoher Inflation und nach
der Marktöffnung sogar unter
Hyperinflation denn noch gelang es von
ihnen sich über Wasser zu halten da sie
es schafften auch ihre Produktivität zu
erhöhen dies war zum Beispiel in Polen
der Tschechoslowakei und Ungarn der Fall
die russische Wirtschaft hingegen brach
einfach zusammen das BIP des Landes Land
innerhalb weniger Jahre um die Hälfte
aber wie konnte es dazu kommen
[Musik]
nun das ist wohl zum Teil auf
Korruptions zurückzuführen denn jetzt
ihnen wollte zwar alle staatlichen
Unternehmen privatisieren hat diesen
Prozess aber so katastrophal
durchgeführt dass all diese Unternehmen
letztendlich in den Händen einiger
weniger Oligarchen landeten er ist daher
bis heute als räuberische Aneignung im
Gedächtnis geblieben der
Privatisierungsprozess ähnelte hierbei
statt jedem der in der Ukraine stattfand
und ja auch in allen anderen ehemaligen
Ostblock-Staaten waren die
privatisierungsprozesse extrem korrupt
aber eben nicht so durchgehend und
absolut wie in Russland die Polen und
Tschechen bezogen von Anfang an im
großen Umfang westliche Investoren wie
zum Beispiel Volkswagen ein und diese
brachten ihre Erfahrungen und ihre
Firmenkultur mit diese ist zwar auch
nicht immer rosig aber immerhin besser
als die der Sowjet Wirtschaft
grundsätzlich gab es in allen ehemaligen
Staaten des Ostblocks zwei Fraktionen
die jeweils ihr Privatisierungskonzept
durchsetzen wollten die eine meinte der
beste Weg seiner Verkauf an erfahrene
ausländische Investoren welche die
rückständige Wirtschaft nicht nur mit
ihrem Kapital sondern auch mit
westlichem und Managementstil wieder
konkurrenzfähig machen sollten Nachteil
dieser Strategie eine großer Teil der
Volkswirtschaften landete so in
ausländische Hand in Polen Tschechien
und Ungarn wird deswegen heute ein
großer Teil der dortigen
Wirtschaftspolitik nicht in ihren
Hauptstädten bestimmt sondern an Orten
wie zum Beispiel Wolfsburg genauso
fließen deswegen gigantische Summen an
dividendenerträgen ins Ausland ab
anstatt investiert zu werden zum welche
mittlerweile übrigens sowohl die
anfänglichen Investitionen als auch
sämtliche EU-Subventionen welche dieser
Länder empfangen haben weit übertreffen
und diese Entwicklung wurde von der
zweiten Fraktion vorhergesehen sie war
der Auffassung die privatisierten
Betriebe müssen auf jeden Fall in den
Händen inländischer Eigentümer landen
zwar wäre damit kein so schneller
Aufstieg möglich am Ende würde jedoch
mehr Reichtum im Land verbleiben und
reinvestiert werden wovor schließlich
alle profitieren würden das Problem
dieser zweiten Strategie war natürlich
das in diesen Ländern nach dem Fall des
Kommunismus so gut wie niemand über das
notwendige Kapital zum Erwerb der
Firmenanteile verfügte bis natürlich auf
die Staatsbetriebe selbst und ein paar
zierliche Gestalten die sich bereits
unter dem Kommunisten durch Korruption
bereichert hatten wie sollten für
ausreichend Inländer anders notwendige
Kapital kommen nun in den meisten Fällen
entschieden sich die damaligen Politiker
bewusst dafür dass dies durch Korruption
erfolgen sollte die kohlephilosophie
dahinter wer die Fähigkeiten besitzt die
richtigen Beziehungen zu Akteuren beim
Staat bei Staatsbanken und
Staatsbetrieben aufzubauen macht euch
Bestechung damit diese Ihnen das Kapital
zum Aktien Erwerb meist durch
unbesicherte Kredite zu spielen wird
wohl auch ein findiger Unternehmer sein
natürlich wurden diese Kredite meist nie
an die Staatsbanken und Betriebe
zurückgezahlt in manchen Fällen nie eine
zu privatisierende staatsfirma jemanden
jenes Geld mit denen er sie dann selbst
aufkaufte offiziell konnten sich an den
Privat alle Bürger beteiligen durch die
breite Verteilung von Anteil Coupons
aber woher sollten diese das Wissen
haben welche Staatsbetriebe eine Zukunft
haben und welche pleite gehen würden
große Teile der Wirtschaft waren
schließlich hochgradig marode über das
zu Evaluierung der Investitionen und
Führung der Unternehmen notwendige
betriebswirtschaftliche Insiderwissen
verfügten sowieso nur jede
Führungskräfte die bereits als
wissenschaftliche Management Kader unter
den Kommunisten in entsprechende
Positionen gekommen waren das Ergebnis
war es auch hierbei eine starke
Kapitalkonzentration und deren sich in
der Geschichte Slowakei und Polen beide
Fraktionen die Inlands als auch die
Auslands privatisierer die Balance
hielten so dass dort ein mehr oder
weniger gesunder Mix entstand setzen
sich in Russland fast vollständig das
inlandsmodell durch natürlich gab es
auch in Russland internationale
Investoren aber diese Märkten schnell
das ist in dem Land so gut wie keine
Rechtssicherheit gab für viele war
einfach das Master Korruption die Höhe
der Bestechungsgelder zu hoch die dafür
notwendig waren damit einem das eigene
Geschäft nicht einfach gestohlen und
Politiker Amigos und Mafiosi zugespielt
wird und Russland lief so in eine lose
Situation während andere
postkommunistische Länder durch ihre
Aufnahme in die EU dazu gezwungen waren
ihre Rechtssysteme auf Vordermann zu
bringen wurde in Russland das
sowjetische System nie richtig
abgeschafft der Einfluss von Politikern
und gut vernetzten auf Justiz und
Polizei blieb immer entscheidend dies
schreckte natürlich nicht nur
ausländische Investoren ab sondern auch
viele musste schon neue Kapitalisten an
sich
[Musik]
schließlich konnte es jederzeit jeden
treffen wenn sich mal die
Machtverhältnisse etwas verschieben
sollten während die polnischen und
tschechischen neureichen daher ihre
Gewinne meist in ihren Ländern
reinvestierten und dadurch zur Stärkung
der Zivilgesellschaft beitrugen
verschoben die russischen Milliardäre
nicht nur ihre Vermögen ins Ausland
sondern auch gleich ihre Familien und
ihren eigenen Lebensmittelpunkt damit
entstand für die Russen wie gesagt eine
loose Situation sie wurden immer
ärmer jetzt ins Beliebtheit Sankt daher
sehr stark und der russische Kongress
plante zum Beispiel bereits 1993 nur
zwei Jahre nach seinem Amtsantritt einen
Misstrauensantrag gegen ihn tja und als
Antwort löste er per Dekret den
Volkskongress und den obersten Vorwert
einfach auf woraufhin eine passsituation
entstand da das Parlament sich weigerte
sich den Anweisungen zufügen und in
seinerseits für abgesetzt erklärte diese
partsituation wurde erst aufgelöst als
ich unterstütze des Parlaments
entschieden gewaltsam vorzugehen und was
glaubt ihr wieder gute alte Jelzin
darauf reagiert hat nun passt gut auf
Truppen und bewaffnete Gegner aus dem
Parlament zu vertreiben in der
Hauptstadt tobt ein erbitterter Kampf
das Weiße Haus in Moskau der Sitz des
russischen Parlaments wurde von Panzern
geschickt hat beschossen spätestens da
wurde jetzt klar dass die Demokratie
wohl doch nicht so schön ist wie er sie
sich zunächst vorgestellt hatte Tage
später entwarf er dann als Reaktion eine
neue russische Verfassung um zu
verhindern dass das Parlament ihn erneut
überschattet in dieser wurde zum einen
die Machtposition des Präsidenten
gestärkt aber natürlich wurde auch der
Versuch unternommen den Präsidenten also
passiert sind wieder eine demokratische
Legitimation zu verschaffen
[Musik]
und interessanterweise erhob nach diesen
Ereignissen niemand im Westen seine
Stimme gegen GLC im Gegenteil der
damalige Präsident der USA will Clinton
sagte er beschwichtigend folgendes über
seine russischen Amtskollegen
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass Jelzin
betrunken besser ist als die meisten
Alternativen nüchtern und nein das war
nicht einfach nur so daher gesagt wenn
du nämlich mit dir jetzt ihn feiern
gehen würdest kennst du auch nüchtern
zurück denn er hätte nicht nur sein Wort
kann sondern auch deinen und den deiner
Freunde weggesoffen ohne mit der Wimper
zu zocken die Weltpolitik hat uns zwar
schon viele große Alkoholiker beschwert
die in die Geschichte eingegangen sind
aber jetzt hin ist hier tatsächlich der
Gipfel ich meine schaut euch einfach mal
folgende Schlagzeile an Bares in
betrunken in Unterhosen vor dem Weißen
Haus gefunden als er versuchte ein Taxi
zu rufen weil er Pizza essen wollte das
größte Problem dabei war für den Besten
gab es keine echte Alternative zum
trinken wollte jelzine er war im Grunde
der einzige in Russland der garantieren
konnte das im Land nicht wieder die
Kommunisten an die Macht kommen oder gar
vollkommen wahnsinnige wie sirenowski
jetzt sind Verstand ist nämlich die
lokalen Gouverneure richtig zu bestechen
damit diese ihn in den Regionen die
Stimmen für seine Wiederwahlen sicherten
und zwar egal mit welchen Mitteln dafür
braucht er vor allem eine men Welt dass
ihm die Oligarchen besorgten also nein
echte Demokratie hatte genauso wie ein
Rechtsstaat in Russland eigentlich nie
eine Chance gehabt und das jetzigen ein
trunken wollt war störte die meisten
Russen nicht sonderlich im Gegenteil er
wirkte damit viel mehr als einer von
ihnen schließlich hatten die Herrscher
im gremel bereits seit der Zarenzeit
denen massenalkoholismus im Volk gezielt
herangezüchtet um es besser beherrschen
und ausbeuten zu können für jenen
landesweiten Zustand der mentalen
Benebelung mit welcher die Briten als
China niederrang Stichwort Opiumkrieg
sorgten die russischen Herrscher also
immer selbst und zwar bis heute aber ein
Volk dass ich im kollektiven Vollrausch
befindet wird seine Probleme nie lösen
können und wenn dann auch noch der
Präsident dauernd dicht oder benebelt
ist komm schnell noch viele weitere als
wirtschaftliche Probleme hinzu 1994 zog
Russland in den Krieg gegen
tschetschenisches Separatisten zu diesem
Zeitpunkt sollte man meinen dass die
Situation nicht mehr schlimmer werden
konnte aber da dachte war es jetzt nur
hold my Vodka
[Musik]
Phönix aus der Asche oder Asche zu Asche
1995 war die wirtschaftliche Lage in
Russland immer noch sehr düster ist das
entwickelte die jetzt in Regierung ein
neues Konzept für die zweite
Privatisierungswelle deren wichtigster
Bestandteil der Verkauf von
aktienpaketen von Großunternehmen war
die Idee hierbei war die bereits erwähnt
dass die oligarischen dem russischen
Staat Geld leihen und dafür im Gegenzug
die Leitung der wertvollsten staatlichen
Unternehmen übernehmen durften darunter
befanden sich wichtige und profitable
Industriebereiche wie mineralunternehmen
und eine Reihe von Betrieben der
Montanindustrie das ganze Programm
nannte sich lones for shares also
Kredite für Aktien denn die
entscheidende Passage die eigentliche
und verdeckte Agenda Jelzins und der
Oligarchen wurde im Kleingedruckten
versteckt wenn der Staat die Kredite
nicht pünktlich zurückzahlen würde
konnten diese Kredite in Aktien an
Staatsunternehmen umgewandelt werden und
was glaubt ihr was dann wohl passiert
ist ganz genau die oligarischen
Übernahmen riesige Unternehmenswerte zu
einem Schnäppchenpreis der damalige
König der russischen oligarischen Bares
parisowski übernahm zum Beispiel die
Ölgesellschaft in Wert von 3 Milliarden
Dollar dank eines dar von 200 Millionen
Dollar an den russischen Staat so macht
einkaufen doch richtig Spaß oder aber
das war nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
eines von vielen Beispielen aus dem
perfiden cryptokratensystem das Russland
damals beherrschte und noch immer
beherrscht wenn bis 1969 hatte jetzt ihn
damit bereits eine ganze Generation von
Milliardären geschaffen die ihm alle
frei nach dem Motto eine Hand wäscht die
andere Gefälligkeiten schuldig waren und
glaubt mir diese Milliardäre haben sich
revanchiert und wie ganz einfach mit den
zuspielen von WLAN
im Jahr 1996 fanden nämlich in Russland
Walenstadt wobei sich nun der Großteil
der Medien in den Händen der Oligarchen
befand jetzt ins Hauptgegner war damals
ein gewisser genau dieses juganov und
nebenbei bemerkt dieser Herr ist bis
heute obwohl diese Wahl bereits 26 Jahre
her ist immer noch der Vorsitzende der
Kommunistischen Partei ihr seht also
Führung auf Lebenszeit liegt wohl
einfach in jedem Mix aus Blut und
Ethanol der durch russische Adern fließt
und der Punkt war das nun die Oligarchen
Nielsen vorbehaltlos unterstützen und
ihr ziehen damit sehr zufrieden zu sein
na war dieser Mann nicht einfach nur
knuffig wie Winnie nur halt auf Wodka oh
ja es waren gewiss gute Zeiten für
jetzigen und die Oligarchen aber umso
schlechtere Zeiten für die Mehrheit der
Russen und so kam es wie es kommen
musste 1998 war Russland pleite
die russische Währung verlor über Nacht
70% ihres Werts doch damit war der Fall
des Rubels noch nicht zu Ende in
dezember 1998 brauchte man sage und
schreibe dreimal so viele Rubel um ein
Dollar zu kaufen wie noch im August das
einzig gute daran war dass es eine Krise
wie man so schön sagt auch eine Chance
bieten kann denn in diesem Fall
ermöglichte eine schwache Währung ist
den Unternehmen eines Landes
wettbewerbsweger zu werden und so wurde
1998 zu einem Wendepunkt für die
Volkswirtschaft die russische Wirtschaft
wurde wiederbelebt und jetzt ist
Wirtschaftsreform begann endlich die
Wirkung zu zeigen
[Musik]
1999 war das erste Jahr einer Periode
des Wirtschaftswachstums das bis zum
Ausbruch der großen Rezession in den
Jahren 2007/2008 anhalten sollte
zwischen 1999 und 2008 wuchs die
russische Wirtschaft im Schnitt um 6,9%
pro Jahr dabei spielt jedoch vor allem
der Ölpreis eine große Rolle der Preis
für ein Barrel brennt wohl stieg von 10
$ Anfang 1999 auch über 50 $ im Jahr
2005 und erreichte im 2008 da 140 Dollar
und die Person die am meisten von diesen
Punkt profitiert hat war wohl niemand
anderes als Wladimir Putin bis 1998 war
er zum Chef der KGB
Nachfolgeorganisation FSB aufgestiegen
im August 99 wurde er plötzlich von
heals hin zum Ministerpräsidenten
erklärt und nur kurze Zeit später am 31
Dezember sogar zu dessen Nachfolger als
Präsident des Landes tja so geht
Karriere gut kritische Stimmen behaupten
die klicke um jetzt ihn habe mit der
Putin einen Deal geschlossen Immunität
gegen einen schnellen Rücktritt und eine
reibungslose Machtübergabe und Russland
hatte somit eine neue
Ära begonnen
[Musik]
die Ära der Silo Wiki
das Wirtschaftswachstum kurbelte den
Konsum in Russland an und die Russen
begann endlich eine Verbesserung ihrer
Lebensverhältnisse zu bemerken nachdem
sie die sowjetische und Post sowjetische
Stagnation hinter sich gelassen hatten
Putin traf zunächst gute Entscheidungen
er wählte André ilarionov einen
libertären Wirtschaftswissenschaftler zu
seinem wichtigsten Wirtschaftsberater
seine Regierung vereinfachte und senkte
die Steuern und er nutzte die
milliardenschweren Einnahmen die der
Staat durch die steigenden Rohölpreis
erzielte zunächst aufrecht
vorausschauende Weise gegenüber Jelzin
wirkte Putin natürlich wie ein
gewaltiger Gewinn ersoff nicht wie ein
Loch und konnte sogar ordentlich
russisch sprechen mit seinem
charismatischen und eloquenten auftreten
Drucke eine Maske die viele vergessen
machte dass man einem alten kgb-spitzel
nie über den Weg trauen darf egal wie
lange er sich auch verstellen und seine
wahren Absichten zu verbergen mag aber
mal Hand aufs Herz wer hat bei einem
Blick in seine Augen nicht jenes mulmige
Gefühl bekommen das ganz natürlich
unterbewusst aufkommt wenn man es mit
einem gefährlichen und er irgendwie
verschlagenen Menschen zu tun hat auch
wenn man die ur machen nicht genau
benennen kann
zu Putins Maskerade gehörte auch die
Durchsetzung vieler in den 1990er Jahren
konzipierten Reformen darunter auch
Gesetze zu Verbesserung des
Justizsystems doch dieses russische
rechtsstaatstheater endete recht schnell
mit dem Fall Jukos dessen Eigentümer
michael kordokowski war 2013 reichsten
Mann des Landes aufgestiegen an seinen
Firmen Imperium das hauptsächlich aus
Yukos und der Bank Männertag bestand war
er so wie alle anderen olligarchen mit
Hilfe von Bestechungen und der
unrühmlichen Kredite für aktienmasche
gekommen doch horakowski war anders als
die übrigen russischen Oligarchen
ähnelte er ihn in Polen und Tschechien
und wollte sauber werden schließlich ist
dies eine bewährte Praxis viele mafiose
egal ob in Italien in den USA oder
Deutschland sie steigen optimal in einem
Umfeld auf in den Kriminalität und
Korruption gedeihen sobald sie jedoch
oben angekommen sind merken sie dass
dieses Umfeld für den Erhalt ihrer
Vermögen und ihrer Stellungen eher
ungeeignet ist außerdem wollen sie ja
meist nicht dass ihre Kinder auch
kriminell sein müssen sondern in einer
friedlichen Umgebung aufwachsen und
leben können doch im Gegensatz zu den
anderen russischen kollegahischen Zug
oder kowski mit seinen Milliarden und
seiner Familie hierzu nicht ins Ausland
er betont immer wieder seine starke
Verbundenheit zu seiner Heimat und baute
seine Firmen so um dass sie westlichen
Transparenz und führungsstandards
entsprachen auf diese Weise wollte er
seinen Konzern für internationale
Investoren sicher und attraktiv machen
und damit in die gleiche liege
aufsteigen die Shell BP und chevrol mehr
noch er wollte diese Geschäftskultur in
ganz Russland durchsetzen hierzu
investiert er großes Turm in den Aufbau
einer demokratischen Zivilgesellschaft
und hegte auch politische Ambitionen das
Problem war nur dass er mit diesem
Schwenk zu einer Saubermann Strategie
einem Mann ganz gewaltig gegen den
Strich ging Wladimir Putin im Jahr 2003
verhaftete der russische Staatlichkeit
rudolkowski nur ein Jahr später wurde
Jokos aufgelöst und sein Vermögen RAS
nervt einer staatlichen Ölgesellschaft
zugespielt wegen Steuerbetrugs
verurteilt wurde holakowski in Sibirien
inhaftiert er verbrachte ein Jahrzehnt
im Gefängnis bis er von Putin begnadigt
wurde seitdem liegt dem Exil im
Vereinigten Königreich der Fall Jokos
war der Beginn von put Weg gegen die
alten Oligarchen in der Bevölkerung war
dies ein sehr populärer Schritt denn die
meisten Menschen waren zu Recht der
Meinung dass diese dubiosen
Geschäftsleute sich den russischen
Reichtum zu Unrecht angeeignet hatten
aber das Problem ist das Putin diesen
Krieg nicht geführt hat um
Rechtssicherheit und eine wirklich
liberale Wirtschaft zu schaffen in der
es beispielsweise wirklich ein
Wettbewerb zwischen den Marktteilnehmern
gibt stattdessen hat er einfach die
alten Oligarchen gegen neue ihm
treuoleganischen ausgetauscht
für die Russen bedeutet dies vom Regen
das heißt von Jelzins Amigos in die
Traufe also zu Putins Amigos bei
letzteren dominiert die Gruppe der
sogenannten Silo Wiki das sind Personen
die aus dem Militär oder aus einem der
Geheimdienste wie zum Beispiel den KGB
stammen und so bedeutenden politischen
und wirtschaftlichen Positionen kamen
dabei sollte man nicht vergessen dass
Putin seine Karriere ebenfalls als
kgb-spion begann ja geradezu von einem
inneren Drang gesessen war ein Spitzel
zu sein Preis als Jugendlicher soll er
sich beim KGB beworben und
regimekritische Mitschüler verpetzt
haben der KGB war dabei eine
Organisation die in der Sowjetunion
alles kontrollierte in jeder Firma sah
zum Beispiel ein KGB Agent und
überwachte den Betrieb und die
Mitarbeiter in ihm liefen alle wichtigen
Informationen über das
Wirtschaftsgeschehen und alle
Hintergrundinformationen über dessen
Akteure zusammen und diese konnten die
kgb-leute später nutzen um als
kapitalistenkarriere zu machen ein
Beispiel eines der wichtigsten
Unternehmen in Russland ist die
Ölgesellschaft rasiert ihr
Vorstandsvorsitzender ist seit 2012 ein
gewisser Igor satchy in eine ehemaliger
KGB Spion und Putins rechte Hand aus
seiner ersten Jahre in Grimmen ich weiß
dass sein Name euch wahrscheinlich nicht
sagt aber wer solche Schlagzeilen wie
die folgende produziert könnte schon
eine interessante Persönlichkeit sein
wie Russlands Darth Vader aus dem
Schatten auftauchte und Putins ölzar
wurde wie ihr seht regiert in Russland
nach wie vor der klüngelkapitalismus es
ist die Ära der Silo WG wie schon bei
den römischen Kaiser bestimmt nun Putins
Finger über das Schicksal von Russlands
neureichen jeder Unternehmer der
versucht ein Vermögen zu machen weiß
dass er die Kunst des Staates verlieren
kann wenn er aus der Reihe tanzt so
gierig wird oder weil sein Vermögen für
einen von potenzieller Wiki einfach
attraktiv zu werden scheint
[Musik]
da ist zum Beispiel die Geschichte von
Egor puschkares als Besitzer eines
großen zementunternehmens entfernen
Osten Russlands trat buschkarre auf der
Partei Putins vereintes Russland bei und
wurde 2018 Bürgermeister von wladiwo
Stock gewählt im Jahr 2016 fordert er
bei den Vorwahlen der Partei wladim
Gouverneur der Region heraus daraufhin
riecht mit Olschewski wohl bei seinem
Freund Putin an und seht selbst was dann
passiert ist Bürgermeister von wladimos
Stock wegen Korruption und
Amtsmissbrauch angeklagt aber die
Geschichte welche das Problem der
russischen Wirtschaft wohl am besten
illustriert ist zweifels ohne die von
Vladimir duschenkov dieser feine Herr
ist der Eigentümer von Systema einer
Investmentgesellschaft im Jahr 2009
kauft das System für zweieinhalb
Milliarden Dollar eine
Mehrheitsbeteiligung an den mittelgroßen
Ölunternehmen bei schnell zu seinem
leitwesen wuchs das Unternehmen aber zu
schnell und wurde dank seiner
Raffinerien zu einem der größten
Produzenten von Öl Derivaten und was
glaubt ihr was dann passiert ist im Jahr
2016 wurde wladimirkov verhaftet
der Grund für seine Verhaftung war
haltet euch fest dass er sich einfach
weigerte diese Ölfirma an den
Riesenrassen jetzt zu verkaufen dessen
Chef damals schon ein Putin Amigo war
und jetzt duschenko wurde erst dann aus
dem Gefängnis entlassen alte akzeptierte
seine Anteile an Barsche für 5,2
Milliarden Dollar also inklusive einer
schlappenentschädigung von 2 Milliarden
Dollar zu verkaufen ja später hat der
gute alte jetzt Geschenk auf seine
Lektion gelernt und er sagte der Staat
hat das Recht Entscheidungen zu treffen
die der Wirtschaft gefallen oder auch
nicht es könnte unangenehme Konsequenzen
für jemanden haben für uns gab es welche
aber so ist das Leben die Wirtschaft
sollte für das Wohl des Staates Arbeiten
sobald sie das aus den Augen verliert
passiert immer etwas Unangenehmes das
Problem hierbei ist jedoch mit Staat ist
nicht das Volk und dessen Wohlergehen
gemeint sondern einfach nur sein
absolutistische Herrscher Putin und
seine Freunde für ihren macht Erhalt
wird alles geopfert inklusive der
Zukunft des ganzen Landes russland hat
die ganze Zeit versucht die
Modernisierung seiner Wirtschaft primär
als technologische Frage zu lösen ohne
damit jedoch nennenswerte weitergekommen
geschweige denn global Konkurrenz wie
ich geworden zu sein eine Strategie der
Öffnung hin zu internationalen Märkten
wurde durch Putin gezielt hintertrieben
von Rechtssicherheit und einer gerechten
Verteilung des Wohlstands kannst du
Schweigen diese wurden ja bereits von
nilsi mit Füßen getreten Tatsache ist
Putin hat nie besonders viel von
Wirtschaft verstanden er dachte ein
Aufstieg wie der Chinas wäre ein
Automatismus dem ist aber nicht so
dahinter steht vor allem viel
Fleißarbeit zu der sich die Russen im
Gegensatz zu den Chinesen nie aufgerafft
haben bzw nie motiviert wurden die
Eliten des Landes verdienten schließlich
genug Geld mit dem Export von Rohstoffen
und zu deren Extraktionen und Verkauf
braucht man nicht viele Menschen der
Großteil des russischen Volkes ist für
die Profite seiner wirtschaftlichen
Führer unerheblich ja gerade zu
überflüssig und lästig er muss nur
irgendwie ruhig gehalten werden durch
billigen Wodka und noch billigeren
nationaljauvanismus Bildung und
emanzipationschancen für die breiten
Bevölkerungsmassen störender nur Stellen
er eine Risiko für die Herrschenden da
denn eine Chance im heute haben wir es
mit einer besonders perversen Form der
holländischen Krankheit zu tun jedem
Fluch des Rohstoffreichtums der die
Ausbildung einer komplexen und
diversifizierten Wirtschaft erstickt zu
diesem Thema haben wir bereits mehrere
Videos gedreht und ich werde sie euch in
der Beschreibung verlinken und im
Gegensatz zu China hat er Russland
einfach das Pech das hier die Ressource
Mensch gnadenlos durch die Ressourcen Öl
Gas und Erze ausgestochen wurden
eigentlich nie eine Chance gegen sie
hatten es hat wie gesagt auch bei der
Privatisierung der Staatswirtschaft die
schlechteste aller Wahlen getroffen
andere postkommunistischen Staaten
fanden meist eine gute Balance zwischen
ausländischen Kapital und genau auf der
einen Seite und heimischen Oligarchen
auf der anderen auch China wählte eine
viel klügere und ausgewogene Strategie
es bot ausländischen Know-how auf den
ersten Blick sehr attraktive
Möglichkeiten behielt jedoch immer die
Mehrheit an den joinventures und damit
an den Kapital gewinnen in Russland
landete fast alles in den Händen
einheimische Oligarchen welche ihr Volk
jedoch in hohem Maße verachten ihr
Kapital daher entweder ins Ausland
brachten oder nur zu ihrem eigenen
Machterhalt also gegen die Interessen
der Bevölkerung zum Einsatz bringen die
Kombination all dieser Faktoren und es
immer krasseren politischen
repressionssystems hat natürlich dazu
geführt dass kluge und leistungsfähige
Menschen das Land seit Jahren verlassen
und woanders ihr Glück zu suchen und wer
würde es ihnen verdenken zurück bleibt
genau jener intellektuelle und
moralische Bodensatz der Gesellschafter
ist Putin und seiner Clique noch
leichter macht das Land und seiner
natürlichen Reichtümer zu beherrschen
und auszubeuten und damit wären wir auch
schon bei der Frage an euch glaubt ihr
das Putin von einem der Wiki abgelöst
werden könnte wie könnte eine
reibungslose Machtübernahme ablaufen
denkt ihr dass diese irgendwann die
Macht an eine andere Gruppierung
abtreten sowie einst die jetziges Bande
an die Putins könnte dies friedlich
ablaufen oder eher nicht oder könnte
Russland doch noch irgendwann eine echte
Wende hinbekommen hin zu einer
Demokratie einer sozialen
Marktwirtschaft guten Kapitalismus was
müsste hierzu alles passieren wie immer
sind auf eure Beiträge und Diskussionen
zu diesem Thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat was ja gebt uns mit einem like teils
mit euren Freunden und vergesst nicht
das Abo mit Glöckchen und keines unserer
Videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch in der uns hält dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den PayPal Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]